we were both on dancing with the stars
oh that's so crazy as hell too
how far did you get i got seven weeks in
wow dude i got six weeks out yeah i got
seven weeks in uh they like are you any
good at dancing they like us guys in
glasses oh they um i was i was actually
pretty good you know i was i didn't feel
like i was terrible with it but my body
was aching
like i had to take epson's hall bath
every sunday right before the show uh
why because you're training so hard i
was training so i thought you trained i
lost 16 out of 16 pounds doing that show
really
and uh yeah wow we train
you you know you film those they make
you feel those crazy packages
more than you than you actually danced
and so i would get frustrated with that
because i was like you know when they're
signing you up you just think okay
you're just rehearsing all day and i
just know myself as a performer that if
i rehearse all day i'm not gonna suck
like not the other way around man like
i'm i just felt
helplessly caucasian man
you know like like i don't have rhythm i
don't know how to dance and i could have
i wasn't like lazy about training but it
was painfully obvious to me that i could
train for 20 hours every day for [ __ ]
six months and i would still suck oh
yeah
there's an it factor there that you were
yeah there's just like my baseline and
my my my my window for potential just
wasn't that i mean look they have the
show has its ringers so it's like every
every season has two to three carlton
yeah two to three people who have like
massive dance experience yeah and for
whatever reason just people choose not
to focus on it and you know they give a
great dance and that's cool but i'm like
you're going to get ice skaters and and
alfonso ribeiro you know apostle grew up
dancing on broadway yeah people forget
that he's right like i'm not gonna let
you chubby carlton this guy out was a
broadway
trained
dancer yeah wasn't he like a michael
jackson impersonator
he trained michael jackson yeah right
didn't he play young michael like in a
music video yeah something like that it
was i think it was a pepsi commercial
yeah okay that famous pepsi commercial
with michael jackson so yeah
yeah dude so we're not a ringer steve
yeah so there was a lot of ringers
though so you can't
steve i hate to break it to you but
they they asked you on the show so you
could lose right no no of course man but
they did the same thing to me
there's there's no doubt in my mind that
that's the case and for me at that time
i had just like come off a pretty like
serious downward spiral i was living in
a halfway house
you know about like uh
you know i
almost exactly one year into sobriety
i'd been in rehab for like heavy like
problems with drugs and stuff and they
like saw that going on they thought
because they love a good transformation
story you know like and at the time i
felt like it uh
it made sense like like you know okay
like i don't know if you know
committing to this life of
being a guy in recovery if being an
attention [ __ ] works with that you know
like working in entertainment and now
like with all this sober stuff and
dancing with the stars was my way of
testing that to see if it could work and
i felt like it was a safe way to do that
but once i got involved in dancing with
the stars it was so stressful man
like i sucked first of all you are
dancing in front of freaking 20 million
people every freaking monday so
you feel shot out of a freaking cannon
with adrenaline right before that [ __ ]
happens and it's live and live tv yeah
and it's live so the other
like one of the things with me i i
haven't talked about this with too many
people but it was like look i know who i
am i know what my legacy is
i'm really kind of an athlete at heart
so i always land on my feet for the most
part
but i knew that had playing having
played the character that i played for
so long i just didn't want to fall
like that was my big fear i was just
like if i fall or i look like a klutz in
any way
it could have been an honest athlete
moment where you just fell or whatever
but for me that was going to be did i do
that no it was just like and it was just
like having that pressure dancing every
week
that was tough and it probably i had my
most fun week one
but then week five i got my joy back
again because i went to train with kim
in new york and so we were away from
everybody so we kind of just kind of
landed off the plane with our dance and
i hadn't been in the the the
you know the crap the media crap all
week because they follow you around
differently yeah you know you know the
tablet guys they don't chase me they're
looking for kardashians and [ __ ] you
know
but that week or when i was on the show
oh
you know tabloid dudes are following you
around all over town yeah i didn't stand
up in front of 1500 people last week my
heart rate went to 170. dancing in front
of 20 million people i'd just be like
you'd pass out it died it's gnarly yeah
it's gnarly i remember like i was laying
in my little halfway house bed the night
before the premiere and i was like i
can't take it i can't take it i gotta
back out like i was having like a panic
attack and it occurred to me then and
ever since that i can't believe that in
all of the seasons of dancing with the
stars that nobody
didn't back out she was too much
pressure and and then on the premiere
there's people that have backed out they
just don't frame it that way everything
is a story line right right right this
person got injured or whatever right
like oh yeah i bet that that makes more
sense oh yeah no everything is
everything is a story and it was like i
hate to say it but it was like if you
did have some you know catastrophic fall
or did some lift and dropped her and she
fell on your head it would be on camera
because they filmed everything they
actually
they loved that they called that this
was the phrase i got from doing the show
they call that good tv
that's my life sprawled out on the floor
right there you call it good tv holy
[ __ ] yeah but the people there are great
man i really did you
after after your experience on dancing
with the stars did you ever go back to
be in the audience yeah just like yeah i
actually went to visit uh calvin johnson
the uh megatron he was on the show and
apparently he grew up being a big fan of
mine so one of his dances he dressed up
as my old character cool so um they
asked me to pop by and uh even when you
you're coming you know you're coming
through the back you know and then the
other dancers are you know val and
whatever really hey yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know it's it's a special fraternity
to be a part it is it's
not gonna sugarcoat the show is
difficult because they tell you you're
gonna get to rehearse this much and you
don't get to rehearse that much but it
is a lot it's just not enough
in five days to pick up an entire style
and choreography and that's what they
want they want you to feel the stress of
it [ __ ] that yeah yeah i mean there's
definitely it's definitely a pressure
cooker yeah
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
this big badass tour bus is coming to
your town with my bucket list tour what
is it well it's an x-rated show full of
all the stuff that i would have never
have been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude